the quiet of an African
night the soft whistle of Wind Through
The Tall
Grass a subtle Creeks of the earth
Cooling in the
dark but the calm is an
illusion and one false step means
death
over the course of a single
night the quiet will be
shattered as rampaging
Giants coldblooded
killers and creatures with a thirst for
flesh bring death to the
Savannah
the African
Wilderness one of the animal Kingdom's
most iconic
Battlegrounds in this vast unforgiving
Place thousands of species of plants
insects and Wild life engage in a
NeverEnding competition for
survival but the familiar daytime
Savannah transforms into something
completely different after the sun goes
down it's a world witnessed by
few and a world many don't
survive
in the fading light of another day's end
young lion cubs seek Comfort by their
mother's
side she's trying to rest before leaving
for the night's
hunt but with a litter of young cubs to
care for that's not always
easy with less and a half an hour before
sunet tensions on the Savannah
rise predator and prey watch each other
from a
distance aware of what's to
[Music]
come the lionesses head out for for the
hunt a signal to others that their world
is about to violently
transform out here Predators on the
night when the cover of Darkness
provides them better chances against the
many prey animals they seek to take
down
[Music]
Darkness
sets and another countdown till dawn
begins
while many of the Savannah's Predators
hunt in packs others prefer to work
alone this is the Assassin of the
grassland a
caracle she's the last thing many of the
creatures here
see if they see her at all
her large tufted ears scan constantly
picking up even the faintest
sounds caracal can take down prey twice
their size but tonight this female's
locked on to something more much
smaller steeping Guinea
foul the caracle misstep alerts are
praying
making it much more difficult to sneak
upon them
unaware now that her prey is awake and
alert she must choose or approach
[Music]
carefully
a
the
hyena thief of the
night
he'll steal the caracle kill if he
can
the Hyena's bold aggression pays
[Music]
off he reaps the benefits of another's
hard
work
she'll go hungry for
[Music]
now but she's not
alone this Savannah brush Forest is
brimming with creatures eager to fill
their
[Music]
stomachs
the thick-tailed bush
baby his day begins when the Sun goes
[Music]
down he might look harmless but this
tiny primate is one of the most
successful hunters in these
[Music]
trees
his large eyes are well adapted to the
darkness and all the dangers lurking
within
[Music]
it he isn't a picky eater and he'll
spend most of his evenings searching for
tree gum and insects to Chow Down
[Music]
On but a gecko makes for a rare
treat it's a risky fast moving Target
and a misstep up here could be
fatal especially when
others
watch from
[Music]
Below in an African brush
Forest a bush baby miscalculates his
strike and hangs on for his
life with a jaw more powerful than a
lion's this hyena would make short work
of this tiny
primate but it'll take more than a
little slip for this expert climber to
fall and the hyena leaves in search of
an easier
meal the bush baby got lucky but the
night is still
young and other Hunters lurk in these
trees
[Music]
including a
snake who has spent months in
hibernation waiting to hunt a very
specific type of
[Music]
prey he smells with a special receptor
on the roof of his mouth called a
Jacobson
organ this six sense works by detecting
the scent particles he catches on his
tongue and light sonar with
smell it allows him to pinpoint the
location of his
[Music]
prey he finds what he's been looking
for a bird bir's
[Music]
nest for him every Hunt is a risk
because if there are birds home they'll
Peck him to
death but it's been months since his
last
[Music]
meal luckily the coast is clear and this
egg eater finds his
prey The
Unborn but his powerful sense of smell
tells him something his eyes
can't these eggs are
rotten a possible explanation for why
the nest is
[Music]
abandoned he'll have to wait a little
longer before breaking his fast
while he continues to search for
food others on the Savannah look for
something entirely
different some are looking for
[Music]
love
this Romeo is a king
cricket and he sends his love song into
the night
sky distances on a savannah can be vast
especially for a ground dwelling
insect if he's going to have any chance
at
romance he'll have to sing his heart out
all night
long
this female here is the
call but she has a long way to go before
finding
him the king crickets Risk Everything
For
Love because others can also hear his
romantic
ballad
[Music]
she makes it back to her burrow as a
crafty killer arrives on the scene
he gives up on the Crickets and moves on
to his preferred hunting
grounds the marshy areas of the
grassland this is the waterm
goose
and in Wetlands he'll eat just about
anything he can get his paws
on but he has a special affinity for
frog
meat he'll spend most of the evening
combing the muddy shallows with his paws
looking for plump amphibian meals
we
in the dark of night on the African
Savannah a giant
approaches
the African
elephant the Titan of the
Savannah some of them weigh more than 5
tons and their strength and power is
unmatched
[Music]
even though they are Plante eaters
African elephants can be extremely
aggressive to any perceived
threat even Lions keep their
distance
[Music]
the herd grazes in relative
peace safe in their size and
[Music]
strength but while most keep their
distance one Hunter senses an
opportunity with everyone else out of
the way the path is
cleared
the elephant has frightened the guinea
foul away leaving their nest
unguarded the egg eater has a
window but he has to act
now if the guinea foul returns turn
while he still in their
nest they will attack and rip him apart
with their
beaks
[Music]
he makes his move but swallowing an egg
several times the size of his head will
take
time
[Music]
he's now at his most
vulnerable and a guinea foul could
return at any
moment by stretching elastic ligaments
in his mouth he Eng gulps the
egg
[Music]
but ingesting the egg is only half the
battle now he has to crack it so he can
drink the Yol
within when he contracts sharp bones
lining the back of his throat pierce the
egg
you only yet evidence he leaves behind a
regurgitated
shell his gamble pays
off before the guinea foul returns he's
back in the
trees while the trees provide safety for
some there a hunting ground for
others like the predatory Katie did
known as The Lion of the insect
World it impales its prey on its biked
legs but even this nightmarish Hunter
must be mindful of a hungry bush
baby
this praying mantis stays
still allowing its camouflage to blend
into the tree
bark
the Mantis camouflage
works or does
it the Mantis
escapes but this is a case of out of the
frying pan and Into the
Fire something deadly hides in the
dark an African tree SC
armed with his venomous stinger and two
powerful front
claws he's a natural-born
killer but like the Mantis the African
tree scorpion is an expert in
camouflage he waits patiently letting
his prey come just a little
[Music]
closer night on the African
Savannah a car call roams hungry after
hyena steals her
meal an egg eater risked everything for
his first feeding in
months
Giants Patrol the
grasslands and on a smaller
stage a deadly face off
unfolds a tree scorpion prepares to
battle a PR
mantis this m SST isn't going down
without a
fight but few escaped the Scorpion's
Claws and he saved his deadliest weapon
for
last
ad do of Venom from his Stinger subdues
the pring
mantis and the Scorpion
[Music]
feeds he tears apart his victim with
tiny claw-like appendages in his mouth
called kicera
[Music]
as he eats he spits up digest of juices
dissolving the organs of the Mantis into
a slurple
stew while scorpion devours his prey in
the
trees another small Savanah resident
navigates the
undergrowth
the South African soft fur rat emerges
at night to scavenge for food while
trying to avoid becoming someone else's
meal
himself but his constant scurrying
inevitably attracts unwanted
[Music]
attention
a puff
adder one of the most dangerous snakes
in
Africa the caracle knows there are some
fights not worth
picking the puff is a perfect Ambush
Hunter
she's a nearly silent stalker with two
powerful
camouflages one Visual and the other
chemical as she gives off no perceptible
scent making her virtually
invisible
camouflaged against the forest
floor the adder settles into
position and
watches
curled up by this L she waits for the
perfect opportunity to pass right in
front of
[Music]
her the puff adder can lie and wait for
weeks hardly
[Music]
moving this is why so many don't see her
until it's too
[Music]
late but when she strikes few snakes on
the planet are
faster
[Music]
in an African savannah a puff adder one
of the fastest striking snakes on the
planet prepares to
attack
if the adder's bite doesn't kill her
prey her Venom
will the rat is
lucky better to be dead than eaten
alive she can go months without eating
and tonight her patience pays
off and though few snakes strike
faster swallowing her prey
whole takes some time
back near the marsh the coast is finally
clear and this male king Cricket tries
again to attract the
meat
his potential Queen has been waiting for
his love ballad to
return the Star Cross lovers are close
at
[Music]
last but a acious African bullfrog has
other plans for this love
story this castanova doesn't realize
he's leading potential
Partners to The Killing
[Music]
Floor at least his love song works for
someone while the bullfrog
digests Life by the water goes
on
and a snake who specializes in
amphibians eyes a tasty looking Reed
frog a young Herald
snake small but
deadly his Venom is harmless to humans
but it's more than enough to take out a
[Music]
frog the frog senses
danger but he might already be too
late the Young snake is still learning
that the slightest hesitation when
hunting frogs can cost you
dinner this
serpent is a snake Hunter
the file snake and his sudden appearance
sends the herald on the
run in this case the more skilled Hunter
wins teaching his prey a final deadly
lesson The Herald snake struggles
against the file snake's
grip but there's no scaping
[Music]
now and because he's a snake Hunter the
foul snake is immune to even the
deadliest
Venoms allowing him to swallow his prey
alive without
worry done is just an hour away and the
bush baby still hasn't had any luck
if he doesn't make a kill now he may not
feed Before
Sunrise but the Savannah offers plenty
of second
chances for the bush
baby sometimes the hardest part of his
Hunt is finding a route through the Maze
of
branches to reach his
prey
his persistence finally pays off and the
bush baby enjoys a nice plump gecko for
dinner but while he
eats something stirs in the grass
[Music]
nearby ESC weed lying Cub searches for
his mother who's out on her nightly
hunt he doesn't realize that his every
cry exposes him to others looking for a
meal
moments Before
Dawn a lost Ling Cub's cries attract a
terrible
Danger I youo won't hesitate to kill
this defenseless
Cub being in the open is a death
sentence
and its only chance of survival is to
hide and be
silent
he locks onto the young one's
calls the
so there's a mother
lion
[Music]
the Hena knows this is a fight he can't
win the distracted Predators give this
dier an opportunity to graze in
[Music]
peace
he's almost made it through another
night but others haven't been so
[Music]
lucky rather than being frightened or
repulsed the sight of Kion lurs him in
and he begins to
feed these gentle grazers are
surprisingly omnivores and will
occasionally eat small
animals in the
dead but he's not the only one looking
for
meat
[Music]
going
first light
death can no longer hide in the
darkness exhausted mother Lions return
to their cubs after the violence of the
night but the hunt never truly
ends the ongoing struggle to survive
continues because out
here
death never
[Music]
sleeps